good evening and welcome to Bethesda
first ever III showcase ladies and
gentlemen this is doomed
tonight we are proud to announce doom
snapback it's an easy to use in-game
tool with uncompromising depth and
capability
you
in Dishonored you play an assassin with
supernatural powers falsely accused of
murder and seeking to stead set things
right
I know Emily called me
here's a peek at what the team at
ZeniMax online studios is bring to
Tamriel unlimited this year
and in the world of entertainment there
are very few things as good as fallen
we're allowing your character while
planning to rebuild and it works like
this you can scrap items in the world
for materials and then use those
materials to build the way you want the
pit boys an important part of Fallout
and we loved it so much we made a real
one but like as far as stupid gimmicks
goes higher shoots the best [ __ ] one
I have ever seen
I've done something else for your
smartphone it is called fallout shelter
you